como ya he hecho varias veces la
presidenta taiwanesa se sube a un avión
con destino a Estados Unidos pasando por
Centroamérica esta vez Es diferente las
crecientes tensiones con Washington hace
que Beijing no permita que este viaje
pase desapercibido
instamos a Estados Unidos a Que respete
estrictamente el principio de una sola
China y los tres comunicados conjuntos
china Estados Unidos que no permita
transitar por Estados Unidos ni siquiera
contactar con funcionarios
estadounidenses el presidente de la
cámara de representantes Kevin mccarthy
tiene otra idea y quiere reunirse con la
presidenta sai cuando aterriza en
California un alto funcionario
estadounidense defendió su viaje
diciendo los periodistas que la
respuesta de Beijing era una reacción
exagerada el año pasado la visita a
Taiwán de la predecesora de mccarthy
Nancy pelosi enfureció a China que envió
a sus fuerzas armadas a realizar
ejercicios a gran escala alrededor de La
Isla sus paradas en Nueva York que los
Ángeles completarán la gira de 10 días
de sai cuyo principal objetivo es ir a
Guatemala y Belice para reforzar las
relaciones son dos de los 13 países que
siguen reconociendo a taipei después de
que Honduras el fin de semana cambiara
su lealtad y reconociera a China antes
de tomar el avión la presidenta
taiwanesa prometió resistir las
presiones de Beijing
la presión externa no obstaculizará
nuestra determinación de globalizarnos
estamos tranquilos y confiados no
sucumbiremos y no provocaremos a otros
Beijing reclama La Isla democrática y
autogobernada y dice que un día hará
parte de China continental